I don't care that she's thin
this film to me is fat representation
so this is Penelope, long story short
family curse makes her have a pig's nose and ears
and this is like very rich blue blood family
and so obviously like they're ashamed of her
so her parents basically pretend she died and have kept her like
locked up for you know
25 years because they don't want her to be seen by the public
and they've been trying since she was 18 to get rid of the curse because she
to be accepted by one of her own
so they're trying to get her to get married to another
like Blue Blood Man
and then when that happens in
the nose will disappear and she'll be “pretty” obviously
but it's like I I wish I could explain it
but you just need to watch it
it's fantastical it's romantic
it's coming of age and honestly
it's like I think kind of ahead of this time
there's like such a good self love message behind this
and like the cast is just stacked
Christina Richie Wednesday Addams right
Reese Witherspoon her friend Catherine O'hara is her mom
and her love interest is James McCoy
Peter Dinklage is also in it
he's like this reporter it's
it's just it's such a good film
and like James McCoy as love interest like
cause also like you watch him grow it just
and her like learning to love herself and like
find love despite this like
big thing that she thought would make people
you know afraid of her and not wanna be around her
you know she thought she like
was unlovable and like
she literally wasn't living as a person because of this thing
I don't know there's very little positive fat representation
so when I watch this film I
I see myself represented in her
obviously I know that she's not fat
but I don't know
there's just some films and some characters that aren't fat but feel fat
coded to me and I'm gonna relate
but like watch this clip
so she goes off on her own and like
goes missing so her parents call the police
police are like okay
like can we have a picture of her so we can know who we're looking
and didn't even have a picture of her
and this is the clip the detailed description
brown hair uh huh
brown eyes uh huh
a uniquely pleasant personality
think pig
so she's a fat girl not exactly
you cannot tell me that that's not fat coated
anyways I love her and this film genuinely
I cannot recommend it enough
please go watch it and enjoy